well let's speak now to women's rights
activist and executive director of the
Iranian and Kurdish women's rights
organization Diana Nami Diana thank you
so much for taking the time on
International women's day
um
it's important
it's a pleasure you know questions it's
still abound as to why we have to have
international women's day my view is
it's a chance to shout about women's
rights and a reminder every year I don't
know what your point of view is in terms
of why it's still important to have this
day
in my opinion it is important because
it's uh just this one day that all
women's around the world coming out to
the streets or wherever they can to
celebrate a day of their rights and
entitlement under the human rights to
celebrate it together
but I would like to pay uh to say happy
International women's day women's day to
every woman in this world to all the
those who fight in Afghanistan in Iran
to come out against bullets under the
bullets and wildlands actually to
celebrate today
and give their
Unity with women around the world
yes it's very much about expressing
solidarity with women who don't have the
advantages of Advanced Women's Rights
that women have been fighting for for
generations and you mentioned
Afghanistan and I just in your
introduction there listed some of the
countries where there are huge problems
for women at the moment in one sense it
feels like you know women take a step
forward but in some countries it's three
to four steps back at the moment perhaps
we could first start by talking about
Iran and what's been happening there
over the last 12 months and particularly
this recent development of it seems
young school girls being poisoned in
their place of Education either for
simply daring to educate themselves or
for speaking out and talking about
women's rights
yeah I have to say that to start the
really give my country my uh tributes to
all who lost their lives during this
year especially in fighting for women's
rights in Iran uh of course the Islamic
regime when they come to power it was a
tool for oppressing the uh the very
right revolution in
1979 and in the second day that they get
the power how many come to the TV and
say women has to cover themselves by
hijab and should not be allowed to come
out otherwise they will be of course
slashed imprisoned and throwing acid to
their face even stoning them to death or
executing them so over the 40 not only
44 years women in Iran has uh has
fighting for their rights has fighting
for their Liberation has fighting again
against this very brutal and oppressive
government and over the past 60 months
with the death of Masa amini when she
was arrested because government says or
morality police says that her hijab is
not properly worn so they arrested her
in two hours she fall into coma and in
three days she was dead passed away
because of torture that they have done
and it sparked a revolution in Iran with
the beautiful and very full
slogan women's rights Freedom origin
Azadi that it's not only in the in in
Iran but it's a it's being a slugging
all around the world because first of
all I have to say that this slogan was
very close to everyone's uh heart from
America as you said that women have been
you know their very basic rights for
abortion has been taken away we are
talking about 21st century in America
that it should be women's rights should
be uh you know uh very much implemented
you know respected uh so countries like
Afghanistan women has been
forbidden from going to school they have
been oppressed in Iran execution killing
women and now you mentioned poisoning
this very young girls children in school
because government really want to first
of all to punish them as Harmony a few
days ago in his his speech say that
these children's is easy to uh to punish
them so after what he says uh the this
in my opinion is not just a simple
poisoning but they have been
biologically chemically have been
attacked first of all anyone so far
three of those girls has been killed
died because of this Gus and it's a way
to keep them away put them keep them at
home not at school because in school it
is very easy for them to communicate and
organize demonstration at home
especially considering the situation
that there is a no reliable internet so
it's much harder for girls and for
children and for boys for the community
to organize themselves to continue this
Revolution and it is a way of punishing
them but considering all this violence
from regime women has been in the street
today we have seen videos coming out
from Iran when women are demonstrating
and in 8th of March they come out to the
Straight Street to celebrate 8th of
March and to giving of course their
their
solidarity with women all the around the
world and for fighting for their rights
for their lives which is the basic
things for every human being in the
world yeah Diana thank you so much for
talking to us about it you know as women
in the west you want to know what you
can do to help on International women's
day you know in the UK we're talking
about the gender pay Gap we're talking
about you know access to child care so
women could actually go to work and
there are other battles being fought in
other countries that it's important to
highlight and in the west we could shine
a light on that and I feel like we're
doing that this afternoon by talking
about it today with you and Diane Nami
thank you so much for speaking to us
here on Sky News we really appreciate it
thank you so much thank you my pleasure